سيدي ، ما الذي شاهدته أثناء وجودك
هناك ، لقد
شاهدت كل الأشياء التي ذكرتها ، لقد
شاهدت أزمة تغذية للأطفال
حيث كان شهر
نوفمبر عندما بدأ هذا قبل ستة أشهر ، كان من
المفترض أن يقوم الناس بالحصاد ، لكن
لا يمكنهم الآن
زراعة التعليم  أزمة أعني أننا نعلم أن
هناك مئات الملايين من الأطفال
حول العالم خارج المدرسة ،
هؤلاء الأطفال ليسوا في
الفصل الدراسي فحسب ، بل في منطقة صراع
، لقد رأوا أنظمة المياه محطمة
ونهبًا والأنظمة الصحية
تتذكر بيكي كثيرًا  تم تطوير هذه الأجزاء
من النمور تمامًا ،
وهناك
جامعات زراعية جيدة ورعاية صحية جيدة
تم نهبها وتم تدميرها
، ومرة أخرى يع
ني الأطفال بشكل خطير جدًا وي
داد الأمر سوءًا كل يو
، هل
مكنك فقط إعطائنا صورة أقصد أن هذ
قد حدث  كان صراعًا
مستمرًا الآن جيمس لمدة ستة
أشهر ، هل يمكنك أن تعطينا إحساسًا
بالتهديدات اليومية
التي تواجهها النساء والأطفال في النمور ،
نعم للأسف  يمكنني أن أعني ، على
سبيل المثال ،
فتاة واحدة ، وفتاة واحدة من بين العديد من الفتيات ، لقد
تحدثت إلى فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا ، وهي تؤدي
أداءً جيدًا في المدرسة.
يومًا تمشي لمسافة 300
كيلومتر
300 كيلومتر مع شقيقها الصغير
على ظهرها
في نعال مكسورة وبعد ذلك عندما
نراها لم تحصل على أي شيء كانت
تبحث فقط عن
فرصة تبحث عن الطعام الآن
ستوفرها اليونيسف في
مساحة تعلم مؤقتة و  سنمنحها
بعض الحماية ، لكن هناك
مئات الآلاف من الأطفال مثل هذا ، لقد
سمعت الكثير جدًا من القصص من
الأطفال
الذين تعرضوا للاغتصاب ، كما تعلمون مثل
فتاة تبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا ، بيكي أعني
أنها فتاة تعلمون أنها شجاعة
وذكية لكنها طفلة
وقد تعرضت للاغتصاب من قبل العسكريين ، هذا
النوع من
الأشياء يعني حقًا أن الصراع دائمًا ما يكون قاسيًا على النساء
والأطفال
ولكن في هذا النوع من السيناريو حيث
لا يوجد خط أمامي وبالتالي
النساء والأطفال كثيرًا
في خضم هذا الصراع ، يكون هذا
وحشيًا بشكل
خاص للفتيات وأمهاتهن ،
ما الذي يفعله العنف الجنسي كسلاح حرب
في صراع مثل
هذا للأطفال والشابات ، أعني
ما هو
تأثير جيمس ،
إنه مفجع أعني حرفيًا إذا
أتحدث عن الأشخاص الذين تحدثت
إليهم أنهم شجعان حقًا ومن الواضح أنني
أتحدث فقط عن هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يمثلون
قمة جبل الجليد الحالات التي
نراها لأنهم
من حاربوا عبر حاجز ثقافي من
العار للإبلاغ  أو
عثرت على مركزنا الصحي أو حصلت على وسيلة نقل
أو اجتازت النزاع
وما أعنيه أن بعض
هؤلاء هم عنيف للغاية
لأن بعض هؤلاء كانوا مجموعات من
الجنود على مدى عدة
أيام أمام طفل أو
أمام زوج
و  ما يفعله هو أنه يحطمهم ،
فأنت تعلم أن أي شخص يسمع القصة قد
سهر في ليالي
هؤلاء الأطفال
وفتياتهم أو أمهاتهم أو أمهاتهم ، لديك سنوات من الوقت للتغلب عليها الآن مرة أخرى.
سأكون هناك ، سنكون هناك مع
الدعم النفسي ، وسنكون هناك
مع مجموعات الكرامة وكل ما في وسعنا ،
لكن دعنا نوضح تمامًا أنك
تعلم أن السلطات بحاجة إلى
إدانة هذه الأشياء علنًا
ويجب أن يعرف الجناة أن
هناك مساءلة و  أن
العنف الجنسي في النزاعات
هو جريمة حرب هو الإنترنت انتهاك
للقانون الدولي
ولكن أولاً وقبل كل شيء على الرغم من كل
الأشخاص الذين يقولون إن هذا يحتاج إلى التوقف ،
فإنه لا يتوقف ، بيكي تعلم أنني رأيت
مركزًا واحدًا
حيث لدينا ثلاث حالات تم الإبلاغ عنها  اليوم
هو قمة الجبل الجليدي ، إنه
مدمر للغاية للأطفال
ومن الصعب جدًا رؤية كيف
يتغلبون على الأمر ، كما أقول
ستكون معهم اليونيسف في كل خطوة على الطريق ،
لكننا نحتاج
إلى أن تتوقف أطراف النزاع عن القيام
بذلك.